♪
We are in basement of Jonathan
Edwards College at the JE Press.
JE Press has been around
since about 1936.
So we are standing
in one of the last remaining
undergraduate
print shops on campus.
[relaxed groove music]
The unique feature
of this particular space
is that we're practicing
typography, essentially,
as Gutenberg envisioned it,
about 600 years ago.
What we are specifically doing
is printing
from handset metal type.
And up until about 1950,
letterpress was just the way
most things got printed.
Almost every college,
had its own printing press
and somewhere in the college
that was sort of a service
for students to use
so that they could
print like programs for concerts
or like posters for events
or their own stationery
or any really
anything that they wanted.
Jesse:
You know, letterpress I think
[sound of machine pedal]
it really is in service
of the undergraduate experience.
[sound of rollers]
It’s not just here for mere
amusement sake like it,
it does provide
a practical function
within the life of the college,
it seems to be a more enriched
form of gift giving.
You know,
this is something that I made
and I'm sharing it with you.
I think that really appeals
to people.
[relaxed music]
The first step of letterpress
printing anything that’s words
always starts with type.
This is a type case.
This is 12 point Centaur.
and each of these cases
contains one font
and a font is one size and style
of a typeface.
[squeak of drawers closing]
We have about
385 typecases
in here in the cabinets
which would be 385
different fonts.
The first step to using type
is composing
and this is a composing stick
and it’s got this adjustable
knee here
so you can adjust how
wide your line length is
or your measure.
Say I want to print the line
“Printing Time”
exclamation point.
I’m starting with a capital P
i know where that is and
these go upside down
left to right, and they line up
with these notches on the top.
Every character is upside down
but it reads left to right
like normal.
This is the process of
setting type.
[sound of metal sliding]
Here is another example of
a set page of type.
This is a little bit fancy
I did this for Valentine’s Day.
So this is our Vandercook SP-20
Now we can ink it up,
take an ink knife
and we’re just gonna
apply it on
♪
Now is the fun part!
We can turn it on.
[whur of machine operating]
Let this down,
and then let down the rollers
I’m going to use two sheets
of news print for thickness
because it’s
pretty thin
but first, we’ll ink the cut.
[click and sound of rollers]
[click]
Set it to print,
line the paper up,
[click]
and you roll it
and the grippers release
at the very end of the bed.
[relaxed synth beat]
The era of letterpress
really wasn't that long ago
and I think allowing students
to participate in it
helps collapsed time in a way
and connects them
to a deeper tradition
[laughing]
Annli: I was a first year
in Pierson,
Yeah! I just was curious
about it and I signed up.
I just kept taking the classes
and I kept just like showing up
and it sort of became
my kind of like
my evening ritual
throughout all of first year
There we go! Nice!
Nice it’s beautiful!
The quality of the work that
people put out
after only a few
months of training
is really impressive.
I think that the
constraints of it
being limited by size
and the number of sorts
we have in a type case
and time
creates such a fertile breeding
ground for people’s creativity
even if they don’t
consider theirself
a particularly creative person
being forced to work in
these constraints
produces incredibly
imaginative stuff.
Jesse:
Letterpress is in a way,
it kind of coordinates the hand,
the head and the heart
in a way that other disciplines
can't really
Yale is a place
that you would come
to be challenged intellectually
and across various
other academic disciplines.
The way that letterpress
forces students
to participate in the craft
and really slows them down
but gives them the agency
to pursue their own
creative ambitions.
I just think that's a
a priceless opportunity
for the right kind of student.
♪♪